hey this is exciting I'm standing with
Dwayne the rock Johnson star of the new
movie rampage rampage you are so good at
action roles you were born to be an
action star
you really were - check this out this is
a picture of you I think this is you at
15 years old that is me at 15 and you
can just see action star now let's
contrast that this is me at 22 I don't
know if you see action star you don't
see actual star no you see bicurious
and I'll be honest with you Dwayne I
still am I have a lot of questions I
don't see what you have that I don't
have I'm being really honest with you
okay you're great-looking guy I clean up
pretty nice you do you're a big guy
check me out big guy okay you have to
rip what I mean well know you're a big
guy you're tall does that mean it means
you're tall it means you're tall you've
been blessed with height but don't you
also see a physique
I see a physique I don't know if I see I
look at this and I'm like I'm looking in
a mirror that's a really yes like a
carnival mirror like the kind of like
the word [ __ ] check this out okay
don't be afraid to check it out
this is you do have a chest yes you see
these senses and they just trail off
into nothing you have a chance you do
have a chest you're like that awkward
Alexa but you have a chest and I have
what they call pecs you don't put your
hand on that okay put your hand on out
what are you feeling I feel a breast
I'm just saying if you saw me let's say
you weren't Dwayne the rock Johnson
yours I okay and you're in a bar and I'm
gonna follow me and I dare I'm mouthing
off and I'm gonna coming at you would
you be at all worried be honest to be
honest with you I I would think I'm
gonna this guy I think if you and I made
a movie together we can kill it come on
we could kill it
why didn't you say that to begin with
Zamboni drift I could be on
we're on Zamboni I know but I wheel an
eyesore on ice they don't drive anywhere
else what about this check it out oh you
yeah or a guy that works out lifts
weights xavius Tommy um you know take a
dump I'm sorry dump truck Oh a magical
dump Trump is a kids movie oh that's
what I thought yes well I mean that's
the movie everybody wants to see I think
Simon and Garfunkel
okay did you do this what I'd like to do
yeah is I'd like to train to be your
stunt man your body double Wow
this way we use me and I can look just
like you and do the stunts and then you
don't get hurt
that's right you know when you ain't
gonna get paid well yeah you wouldn't
have 50/50 on this well did because
that's just not how the model works oh
right you think people are gonna pay
money to see Dwayne the rock Johnson in
a movie I would do that don't do that
that makes me don't do that yeah don't
don't like laughing you like that I
don't like that
I just both urinated and [ __ ] okay I
will prove to you okay
great
body double stunt double first is to
become you through very minor
alterations okay and I'll be right back
rampage lab great chaos whereby few
things out I just want to show you that
I can do it okay cuz I know that you
question my physicality yeah but that
was your first mistake and you don't get
a second chance okay it's that long that
someone would do it huh well they would
but probably with a little bit more
confidence well that was your first
mistake and you don't get a second
chance you don't get a second chance
well I don't know you have to go up like
that like you questioned it that's your
first mistake you don't get a second
chance
you didn't be like hit it I'm in a weird
with like jazz you made a mistake you're
the first time when we make a mistake
second time they'll be chances that was
your first mistake you do not and I
stress and do not get a second chance
because I will draw the line mamacita
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay it wasn't good take it when you're
ready yes you cut right there right
there okay and where were you exactly
because I want to I don't want anyone to
see where you it was about right there I
had this here and where I began there we
go three two okay
that was I thought I nailed it
I thought that it was supposed to be a
launch right but this was more like a it
was more like a like a roll so what you
saying you want I want it again how did
you feel I guess I think we should also
do it again great you know what I'm not
feeling really pain at all it's like a
bottle of genie would come out of this
you never see that in a laboratory no I
know but it's special
[Applause]
gorilla yeah rampage yeah and his name
is George
why did you some stunt scenes to show
you that I could work with George and
fit into the movie rampage with my stunt
work come on in George again
he's constantly expensive but this was
pretty good pretty much well then this
is pretty much a piece of [ __ ] well I
mean what well I think with a little CGI
this would look exactly like the albino
hey I can't believe this
what we gonna do no he can hear you
again I'm sorry he can hear me yes oh
god I hate I'll give all right the
genetically-modified yeah two crabs you
yes cut okay take out the star his
identical twin steps in and I handle the
action let's do this okay and action
bring out that a-okay
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
first chance and you don't get a second
one check it out if you like this it's
exactly the same thing
stupidity thanks to Dwayne Johnson he's
hilarious rampage will be in theaters
April 13